I reckoned that this dome here on a
windswept field in Denmark is the
world's most frustrating work of art I
know that's a bold claim so let me
explain this is Elia designed by an
artist called Ingvar cron hammer he's
famous for dark industrial art art that
looks like machinery art that looks
alienating and remote Elia certainly
qualifies as all that it's been here
near the town of Herning in Denmark
since 2001 32 metres high if you include
those chimneys the steps up to the
viewing gallery are uncomfortably large
it feels like it wasn't designed for
humans comparisons to an alien spaceship
that's landed in the middle of ruled
Denmark well the cliche but standing
here they feel about right something
feels wrong about this sculpture which
is all very impressive but that's not
the frustrating part in the middle just
between those four pillars there is a
gas burner and it shoots a massive flame
eight meters in the air a huge blast of
fire it's one more ominous unsettling
thing about the sculpture it might burst
into flame at any moment but it probably
won't because it does that on average
for just 25 seconds about once every two
or three weeks at random decided by a
computer it might be months between
eruptions it might just be a few days
and according to an article in the local
news it won't go off if the wind is too
high which it probably is today or if
there are any people too close elyes
website doesn't tell you when the flames
are going to be it just archives the
time and date of all the ones that
you've missed they keep that up to date
just to taunt you I guess I don't know
I'm sure there are a couple of photos or
videos from people online who have been
lucky you can go online and see that but
you can go online and see the Mona Lisa
in much higher resolution than you ever
could in person in incredible detail
that doesn't stop people crowding into
the Louvre in Paris to fight with selfie
sticks there is something about being
there so if Elio calls to you if you
want to see the fire in person you are
going to have to camp out and watch it
24 hours a day maybe four months as for
me I've got about an hour left until I
have to leave to catch my flight so
here's hoping
you